Lachie une complication Supermercado si
étonnamment pour la postérité Oh Tito dosa
Nouveau Findo rempli quand vous dites listo
une détection de co2 Quichotte notre chargeur une
matière première Kim Basinger kim na pali
Ranma Kim Basinger al-charia pas de
centres métalliques de renouvellement accro séparés sur kaito
shion Phil Masi verrouille  écologique donna
kelley blonde volcanique cinéma amérique
comptable famille tartan Evo est un
Machiavel ko2 Cardew table à Santiago
Navi Je n'aime pas les gens qui regardent ma
femme Je suis vraiment entré dans ce projet avec
seulement la pensée qu'elle avait été
victime a une très petite fille et  elle
était, elle n'était qu'une victime et en tant que femme,
elle devait y faire face
de toute façon, je ne pense pas que je savais que je
devrais apporter toutes les émotions que je pourrais jamais
avoir à l'intérieur de moi,
la colère, la rage, je devrais y faire face
blessé d'être la victime non j'ai adoré je
devais avoir une haine pour quelque chose et
c'est très difficile pour moi parce que je ne
suis vraiment PAS une personne qui déteste du tout
allez qu'est-ce que c'est pour la protection
il y a beaucoup de fous là-bas nous avons
dit  considérez un peigne dans l'
actrice dominante avez-vous commandé à la escuela la
beauté un katana pour échapper à une personnalité
Kaposi oh tellement
MMN reste à être donc il y a deux femmes
certainement beaucoup de femmes en moi
mais les deux avec qui je me bats est  une ver
est très timide et très introvertie et
je dois la pousser parce que ça va tellement à
contre-courant de cette affaire et je
dois la laisser derrière ou lui parler
pour rester loin de moi ne viens pas avec moi
aujourd'hui quand le  l'autre doit sortir
tu sais surtout tu sais dans la musique ou
aller sur scène ou faire n'importe quoi de ce
genre de choses parce que tu dois être
sans peur tu dois vraiment avoir peur c'est une
bonne chose mais avoir vraiment peur
si maintenant laisse le  fille timide éloigne-toi de moi
arrête ne t'en sors pas éloigne-toi de
moi alors tu sais que je suis pour deux filles ici
deux femmes à droite